Speaker 1: Let's go to Richard from Jersey.
Richard, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hello, David.
Pleasure to be speaking with you.
Speaker 1: The pleasure is all mine.
Speaker 2: So the thing on my mind right now,
I think the thing on a lot of people's mind
right now is just thinking ahead to the 2024
election.
And it seems to me that the writing's on the
wall that long distance us is more than likely
going to be the Republican nomination.
And I keep thinking about the prospect of
I didn't think of this.
And it seems to me like we're.
Speaker 1: Starting to lose you.
The audio wasn't great to start with.
It started at like a six and a half, but you're
quite literally just fading and cutting out
now.
So I heard you say you think DeSantis will
be the nominee for the Republicans?
It's certainly possible.
I don't know yet.
It's too early for me to say that.
You were then starting to talk about Biden,
and I just couldn't hear a word you were saying.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Does that sound.
Speaker 1: Better?
Yes, it does.
Speaker 2: Beautiful.
So my main thing is I don't think Biden is
going to win against Ron DeSantis, but it's
he's still toting the line of saying that
he is going to run.
And the more time that goes on, it seems that
he's going to.
So I'm wondering what your thoughts are on
is it possible for him to change vice presidency
choice because Kamala Harris herself isn't
very popular either.
Is it possible to get a more exciting, younger,
progressive candidate on the ticket with him
that could possibly bolster his chances?
Speaker 1: Okay, this is a good question.
If Biden runs, could he and should he replace
Kamala Harris, his current VP, with someone
else?
He absolutely could.
I think the problem with that is whatever
benefit Biden might get from, as you say,
a more exciting or likable VP running mate
in 24 could very easily be canceled out by
the fact that bailing on your VP for consecutive
terms might be seen as a sign of trouble in
paradise, for lack of a better term.
So I don't know if I were advising Biden that.
I would say to do that.
I think you want to project stability.
You want to project a steady hand.
And part of that would be this.
This is a good team.
And even if people they're changing behind
the scenes, you go with that with the person
who is currently VP.
Also, it would be very strange and difficult
and awkward to be campaigning for several
months while Kamala Harris is still president
with somebody else as the running mate.
I think it raises I think it creates problems
for Biden to do that.
Speaker 2: Okay.
I take your point that it would be awkward,
but.
My main thing with Biden, as always, is that
he's very low energy.
And even though we were able to get past the
midterms pretty well, I think it would have
been better if we had had a president and
a vice president that inspires people to vote
for something instead of voting against the
greater evil.
And I just I'm looking for things that Democrats
can do to do that for younger voters.
And, you know, voters in general.
Speaker 1: I agree with you generally.
I don't know that replacing Kamala is that
thing, but I appreciate the idea.
Speaker 2: Fair enough.
Thanks for speaking with me, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you for calling in.
That's Richard from Jersey.
Very, very powerful declarations there.